In this video we'll look at the options available for using extensions in Burp Suite Enterprise.
You can add extensions to implement custom scan behaviours and capabilities.
For example, you can create your own custom scan checks.
There are two types of extension.
We have BAP extensions or BAPs for short.
These are community written extensions that we have reviewed against a set of guidelines.
You can download all approved BAPs for free from our BAP store.
You should note that not all BAPs are compatible with Burp Suite Enterprise Edition.
You can also use custom extensions.
These are extensions that you have not downloaded from the BAP store.
You manage extensions by adding them to your extension library.
Once part of your library they can be applied on a site-by-site basis so they are used during scans.
To see what you have available in your extension library you can go to the settings menu and select extensions.
The library is split into two tabs.
One for managing BAPs and one for managing custom extensions.
You can add, view and remove extensions from here.